chéri il ya une émission qu'on adore ces
affaires qu'on connaît qui cartonne sur
france 2 tous les jours et vous avez été
nombreux à nous demander le retour de
chou qui vous souvenez que mokhtar et
john eledjam l'excellent diamé les
dianes avait déjà piégé samuel etienne
dans questions pour un champion pour la
grande race rade mais voilà c'est le
retour de chouki moktar zazou qui s'est
tenue provoque à ahnif cette fois ci tu
as été piégé sophie davant avec donc
john eledjam
alors je vous le dis j'ai encore la
folie sophie davant merci elle merci à
la production d'affaires concoules
regarder et regardez ce qu'ils ont été
brandis c'est parti
[Musique]
découvrons maintenant ce que les deux
amis d'enfance chouki et simon honte à
nous proposer à la vente
nous sommes venus vendre un objet un peu
spécial qui fait une paire de babouches
alors ce sont des babouches qui ont
appartenu à rami 16,2 au roi du maroc et
la chose qu'avec le champ car on est
venu ici parce qu'on espère faire une
affaire conclue et moi sommes en dessous
puis bonjour bonjour vous des babouches
temps alors qu'ils jouent qui est si
mais choqué shocking et si vous que
faites vous dans l'es10 je suis
chauffeur hubert et j'ai aussi un bar à
chicha qui s'appelle chez chat botté si
j'avais des gens le chat botté
exactement un petit jeu de mot chicha
nous avons voulu drôle d'horaire vend
donc c'est peut-être oui merci je vais
tuer un peu le stress quand même ah oui
c'est le stress vous êtes frère non pas
du tout je suis contrôleur de gestion
ok voilà alors des babouches harold et
j'avais passé des paris n'avait jamais
eu dans les bichons n'ai pas eu beaucoup
à l'expertisé non plus elle m dos et ma
bouche on les a achetés dans un souk à
un gerba inquiète et pourquoi les vendez
vos projets on est dans 2 1 2 a eu
besoin d'eux
une paire de babouches
il faut savoir que la babouche c'est un
soulier traditionnelle dans le monde
arabo-musulman et les premières babouche
remontent au 3e siècle après
jésus-christ plus combien à peu près
attendez laissez moi j'ai pas besoin de
moi mon expertise en tout cas c'est une
version citadine c'est une version de
fait on s'en fout en ce moment je suis
donc là nous avons un modèle un petit
peu plus attention pu travailler moi un
modèle un tout petit peu plus travaillé
donc avec avec une ornementation de fils
d'or et des petits cabochons kissa des
diamants et de placer ce sont des
pierres d'imitation c'est ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on me dit gêné j'ai parlé ce
combat sinon c'est combien sont
métalliques
excusez moi et je vois que une des
babouches a été signé par chèque car le
le chanteur c'est sam exactement le
chanteur réclamait les riches à la lutte
je vous sens je pensais que c'était bien
pour le ski ça doit y ait suffisamment
de ces saboteurs ont par là je quittais
pas agressif avec madame mais j'avais
vraiment c'est donc vous les vendez dans
quel but
l'oseille je vais vous proposer une
estimation de 100 euros donc 100 euros
tout ramassé généraux son tour ou non
mais c'est quand même bien travaillé
c'est un travail de fils d'or dans 1000
et 2 90 euros
voici le pass et vous n'aurez plus
besoin profond sur ma bouche
à vous de faire en sorte
la première puce en salle des ventes tu
commences à me casser les couilles
vous réglez vos petits contes la
probable ok merci beaucoup d'être persie
arsenal suffit je suis pas un peu déçu
je suis très très déçu mais après j'ai
deux trois mois de juin la barre non
vraiment je vais de qantara continue
enfin ça c'est pas toi soit déjà en
train de faire passer pour des boulots
celle d'istanbul où quoi qu'il arrive
moi j'ai besoin de jeunes gens repas dit
chez son argent et surtout surtout en
cash
big up à tout le monde arabe
[Musique]
dédicacé ou non les babouches de chou
qui est simon forte séduire nos
acheteurs et dépasser les 100 euros
d'estimation de notre commissaire
priseur
on le découvre tout de suite
bonjour bonjour messieurs bonjour c'est
direct vous lisiez les i c'est pas grave
ne voyez même pas d'où vous venez
comment vous allez bien vous remercie
c'est ce que l'on dit si monsieur
l'année messieurs je me shoote y est je
m'appelle simon ya là vous êtes chacun
venu avec une lampe d'aladin bush délais
dans abu me donne vous avez la gauche
oui vous avez vu en dessous chef khaled
al est long
aïcha oui c'est ça les chats écoute moi
comme cela je ne joue pas je chanterai
les ailes passée 2-1 quand tous les deux
vers de cendrillon version marocaine
elle est ornée de diamants véritables de
tunisie des diamants tunisien quoi
parlera du diamant ces diamants mais
alors racontez nous comment se fait-il
qu'elle soit signé par khaled comment
vous avez réussi cet ex alors on les a
achetés aux os ou de gerba est elle en
tunisie en tout cas voilà dans cet
univers là et elles ont été portées donc
par ramsès ii et le roi du maroc
notamment à huy en tout cas moi je
voudrais en profiter pour saluer tous
nos amis du maghreb qui nous regarde
tous les jours salam aleikoum j'ai
toujours pas compris mais moi je veux
savoir ce que vous faites dans la vie
parce que y'a un truc je suis champion
du val de marne de job très chic
merci beaucoup 85 au carré 25 au carré
absolument
[Musique]
je sais comment on aimerait faire une
affaire conclue ce qui est certain c'est
que vous allez retrouver votre argent d
d'avion je bouffe à julien tu vas
acheter acheter en espage peur à bah
ouais là je crois que c'est ce qui me
concerne moi c'est plus chèque de banque
je connais un peu le monde de la télé
c'est un peu magouille et compagnie du
coup chèque de banque de préférence
c'est possible cela passera par les
bancaires alors moi je vais commencer à
3 ans en france au début ça on laisse
monter les enchères les bus ça peut se
chauffer sont très sales à l'intérieur
où il sans vouloir manquer de respect à
sa majesté ramsès ii je pense que c'est
enfin à l'époque où à la fin les dons
l'oseille l'osé choisi de parler
qu'est-ce qui fait lui non il est
contrarié on peut continuer les enchères
ça ne vous dérange pas excusez moi pas
venu pour ça
sans vouloir manquer de respect
allez 20 25 si tu es 30 juillet parler
tout le temps alors j'ai si on peut
remplacer mais j'espère pouvoir enchérir
ont tu me l'as saint jean le pilote
n'est pas des guignols
non mais quel mandat temps on n'est pas
des guignols on veut savoir maintenant
des pétales et son art de vivre un
manoir à 8,8 euros l'argent constitue le
fait pas c'est en fait dix fois je pense
qu'il va falloir vous séparer un moment
donné parce que ça va se terminer très
noble parce qu'en fait c'est la babouche
gauche les partis m
ouais tu fais parce que moi c'est
attendait en fin d'émission est là et
nous on est on est pour la console on
est pour les personnes venaient bien
récupérer de l'argent pas tuer comme ça
le bouffon cherchant vous êtes nouveau
genre de la vaisselle apporte vous
avouer nous sommes cgc mokhtar mme
l'émission de cyril hanouna pour la
grande brasserie numéro 4 et ben merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci
merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
golez
grasset ce qu'ils avancent l'inversé
tous les états d'âme apparents et toute
son équipe
toute l'équipe raymond qui sont en amour
avec la production je les remercie
encore emerse voilà ils sont super voilà
c'est d amour et merci à eux et sophie
elle est allée génial voilée au début
vous avez comme alessandra ticket aller
mais on la vit il joue ici un rôle elle
arrive en replay de mokhtar et john
regarder parce qu'elle est allée va nous
découvrons maintenant ce que les deux
amis d'enfance chouki et simon honte à
nous proposer à la vente
nous sommes vendre un objet est ce qu'à
un moment tu as senti qu'ils s'étaient
doutés nôtre je crois pas le jury parce
que c'est son nom se sautent sur mon
avis comme étaient en coulisses
ouais voilà la sentinelle tard connu
mais tu es magnifique comme ça et
mokhtar et ses locaux
[Applaudissements]